foreign
and welcome back to Simply learns
YouTube channel I am kaushal and today
we'll dive into the Intriguing world of
computer security in this video we'll
explore one of the most notorious cyber
threats the Trojan what is a Trojan you
ask well let's find out but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these videos
and find them attractive then subscribe
to our YouTube channel because we bring
the best videos for you daily also press
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply learn before we go any
further let's define what a Trojan is a
Trojan is a type of harmful software
that pretends to be something useful or
desirable while actually being malicious
it's like a sneak imposter hiding inside
something you want like a fun game or a
helpful app
once you unknowingly install it on your
computer or device it can secretly steal
your personal information damage your
files or give control of your system to
hackers without your knowledge just like
the ancient story of the wooden house it
looks innocent on the outside but hides
dangerous intentions inside
now that we know the basics let's look
at the different types of Trojans out
there the first one is remote access
Trojans or rats these sneaky Trojans
allows hackers to gain unauthorized
access to a victim's computer remotely
they can spy on users steal sensitive
data and even control the infected
system key loggers Trojan silently
record keystrokes capturing sensitive
information it's like password credit
card numbers and other personal data
they can be incredibly dangerous
especially if you use online banking or
make online purchases back door Trojans
backdoor Trojans create hidden entry
points known as back doors in a victim's
computer once installed they Grant cyber
criminals full control over the infected
system essentially leaving it wide open
for further attacks the last one is
downloaders downloaders as the name
suggests download additional malicious
files or programs onto the victim's
computer they are often used to deliver
more harmful malware to the system you
might be wondering how the Trojan
spreads in first place so let's shed
some light on that
the first is phishing emails phishing
emails are one of the most common ways
Trojans infiltrate systems cyber
criminals craft convincing emails with
malicious attachments or links that when
clicked download the Trojan onto the
victim's computer malicious websites
visiting compromised or malicious
websites can also leads to unintentional
Trojan downloads these sites exploit
vulnerabilities in your browser or use
your social engineering techniques to
convince you to download infected files
the third one is software downloads even
seemingly legitimate software downloads
from untrustworthy sources can be
infected with Trojans always download
software from official and reputable
websites also if you want to master the
field of cyber security then simply
launch postgraduate program in cyber
security in collaboration with MIT is
clearly the right choice for you this
postgraduate program in cyber security
is designed to equip you with the skills
required to become an expert in the
rapidly growing field of cyber security
this cyber security program aims to help
you stay ahead of the latest cyber
security Trends key features of this
program simply learn postgraduate
certificate master classes from MIT
faculty featuring modules from mitscc
and EC Council access to ceh Kit 25 plus
Hands-On projects and many more the
cyber security certification program
begins with introductory level skills
and then progresses to advance cyber
security Technologies
this program covers all the essential
skills you will need to become an expert
in the field of cyber security
cyber security is definitely one of the
top concerns of businesses today in any
industry from securing data to
anticipating cyber attacks and placing
enterprise-wide safeguards to prevent
them employers worldwide are
increasingly looking for qualified cyber
Security Professionals to join them so
what are you waiting for find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below and enroll today
now that we understand the potential
risks let's explore some essential tips
to protect ourselves from Trojans
number one is keep your software updated
regularly update your operating system
web browsers and security software to
patch vulnerabilities that Trojans can
exploit
be cautious with emails and links never
open suspicious emails or click on links
from unknown senders verify the sender's
identity before opening any attachment
third is download from trusted sources
only download software apps and files
from official and reputable sources
avoid Shady websites and torrents the
fourth is use antivirus software invest
in reliable antivirus software that can
detect and remove projects from your
system in conclusion Trojans are
dangerous and deceitful cyber threats
that can cause severe damage to your
computer and compromise your personal
information however armed with knowledge
and proper security measures you can
protect yourself from falling victim to
these malicious attacks a lot of
individuals have attained high salaries
and better career opportunities through
our postgraduate program in cyber
security in collaboration with MIT
University so let's take a minute to
hear it out
hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old and last
year I upskill with simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the IIT sector
in various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccsp certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course course I must say was packed
with practical examples it was led by
highly skilled certified instructors I
worked with many companies before the
security analysts and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course first and foremost I've
been a learner be a learner first
and that's all for this video remember
always stay vigilant and take
precautions while using the internet to
ensure your Online safety thank you for
joining us today as we delved into the
world of Trojans if you find this video
informative don't forget to give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to our channel
for more exciting content we'll see you
next time until then keep learning and
stay tuned to Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here